do you want to get more clients and
sales in your business this year well if
you're listening to this podcast I hope
your answer is yes and today we're going
to be talking about one of the biggest
opportunities in video marketing right
now it's one of the best places to be
posting consistent content in 2020 to
help you grow your business and this
platform that we're talking about today
is LinkedIn now I get it
LinkedIn well it's no longer just the
place to post your platform it is now a
powerful marketing platform where you
can grow a brand you can connect with
your customers and you can grow a
powerful community and in the new era of
all of the rising competition and the
oversaturated marketing that's happening
on the other platforms LinkedIn is wide
open for fast acting smart entrepreneurs
that are just like you did you know that
less than 5% of the people who have
profiles are actually posting content
this means that after today's episode
you are going to have the winning
strategy for getting clients and growing
your business today on LinkedIn
welcome to the big marketing show the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
I'm your host Heather Torres and I'm
Sean Connell and work from think media
and if this is your first time listening
we are fired up you're here this show is
dedicated to helping you learn how to
get your content notice and the latest
money-making strategies that are working
right now online so whether you want to
grow your YouTube channel or you're
ready to maximize video across all of
social media and this podcast is for you
hello and welcome back to the think
marketing podcast I'm fired up for
today's episode because we're talking
all about LinkedIn and the power of
LinkedIn to grow your influence to reach
more people to reach more customers to
generate leads and I'm with the expert
Michaela Alexis who's not only a
LinkedIn coach and trainer she has built
massive influence through LinkedIn and
coaches other entrepreneurs on how to do
that but she's also one of our speakers
to grow a video live this year in Las
Vegas so I am so pumped up to have you
on the show how's it going it's good
it's good came from the snow to the sand
so getting some heat on me although it's
a little bit chilly here today that's
right we're meeting up here at a
conference social media marketing world
in San Diego but for those that are just
meeting you how'd you end up in this
position where you're helping people
with LinkedIn and what's kind of your
background is not so much that is a
great question I feel like my story is
similar to yours and like so many people
where you kind of just started where
you're like trying to figure out
something and then you figured it out
and then you wanted to share what you
figured out with other people and then
all of a sudden you're like whoa
I can actually help other people do this
thing and then the next level is like I
can make a living off of helping other
people do this thing so that's like been
the case for me so I started on LinkedIn
back in 2016
writing articles sharing topics that
people weren't talking about in that
world you know things like fear of
failure and rejection and harassment in
the business world like those very taboo
business subjects that I knew in my
heart that other people were dealing
with but they didn't want to talk about
so I'm like somebody's got to step up to
the plate might as well be me and I'll
just see what happens
and eventually people started saying I
don't know what you're doing but you
teach my business how to do that thing
that you're doing and somehow I landed
into this kind of unicorn job where I
get to do what I love every day so
amazing and your content has helped us
over the last couple years we've been
like really or really about a year have
really been getting into LinkedIn and
been getting some crazy results
I mean it's helped us reach new
customers it's helped us build more
community it's helped us expand our
reach and so as we talk about this for
those listening especially because we
talk about YouTube all the time people
are paying attention to Facebook
everyone's on Facebook sure why LinkedIn
yeah LinkedIn tends to be kind of like
the curt again of social media it's like
it's useful it's handy but it's not
super sexy and so people are kind of
like I have it but you don't really
leverage it that's what I usually hear
from people and my first thought is so
LinkedIn was acquired by Microsoft a few
years ago and I know as a creator when
it was acquired by Microsoft the whole
culture changed it went from being
essentially kind of like a Rolodex where
you had people that you would work with
or potentially work with to all of a
sudden like embracing all these creators
people like professionals people like
close to retirement sharing their
expertise on this platform with six
hundred million people and I don't think
people actually know how big LinkedIn
actually is it's like a quiet giant like
even last year the growth was parallel
with Instagram Wow which is insane six
hundred million users like if you look
at the graph especially after that
acquisition it's just massive and you're
starting to see that shift in the
culture where people are sharing videos
they're sharing articles they're sharing
photos that's something that didn't
exist when I first started actually the
first video and photo that I posted
people were like it's not Facebook it's
not Instagram there's a lot of
resistance to it moving in that
direction and now people have just fully
embraced the fact that this is kind of
like it's kind of like the world's
largest networking event when you really
think about it that makes sense and you
kind of got into some of the
opportunities on LinkedIn yeah I think
that what's been amazing and where some
of our listeners are viewer
might be thinking it's like well yeah I
mean I set up my resume on LinkedIn you
know ten years ago but what really has
been the shift is now it's at content
publishing platforms and so there's so
many different things you mentioned
articles of course photos written word
video has been a big thing but now
there's also like live video and so for
the for the entrepreneur the business
owner or the personal brand content
creator what should they be approaching
LinkedIn with in terms of content
creation so video is definitely hot I
mean it's been around for a few years
now on LinkedIn but it's still kind of
at the very beginning people are just
starting to figure out how to use it how
to leverage it so I think there's still
a lot of opportunity as long as you
understand that the culture on LinkedIn
is not this like boring stiff
conservative platform they think a lot
of people get on camera and they'll do
these very like hi there I'm so-and-so
and they'll talk about how great their
company is for the next ten minutes and
that's not what people are looking for
the business world has changed we don't
have 9 to 5 s anymore right we have
technology so people want to talk about
challenges they want to talk about real
issues they want to talk about their
problems they want to grow they want to
connect and so all your videos need to
kind of be focused on that intention of
growing and connecting so I think that's
a great opportunity
LinkedIn live is super fun I didn't know
if I would actually be into it but
interview style videos are really
exciting I've seen companies really
leveraging it well there's one that I'll
be talking about in my talk at social
media marketing world Gong IO there are
the company to watch in terms of
LinkedIn pages and what they do is they
give away something every 15 minutes so
they have swag or they'll give away a
book every 15 minutes because LinkedIn
and I don't know what it's like on other
platforms for live video but it just
keeps growing the longer that you're on
so I've noticed that the sweet spot is
about 45 minutes being live where you're
really gonna get that maximum impact
that's so smart and then therefore the
viewers they're giving away a book at 15
minutes into the livestream every
minutes they give away another book and
you mentioned something let's clarify on
LinkedIn you can have a company page or
a personal page what's the difference so
personal page it's kind of a face book
right you got your personal profile
what you use to kind of like network
with people and let people get to know
you and then you've got your business
page which should it be kind of like
your service hub so that should house
all of your materials anything that
people might need to make a decision
whether or not to work with you
so I am of the mindset that you should
have both even if you're a solopreneur
so I'm a swole opener I have both I have
my personal profile then I've got my
company page and the contents very
different I look at LinkedIn again as
the world's largest networking event so
I'm constantly sharing you know what are
those milestones what are my challenges
in my career so we'll get on video and
I'll share some of those and then once I
connect with people I hope they go to my
profile see where I work and then put up
their hand to say yes I not only like
and trust you but I want to learn more
about what you have to offer so I almost
use it like a funnel yeah that makes
sense yeah I love it and in just a
second I want to hear some stories of
maybe some people and and what they've
actually done on LinkedIn and what
results has led to and then maybe a
tactic or two but this is just a great
reminder that if you haven't got your
tickets yet to grow a video live go to
growth video live.com Michaela alexis is
gonna be there as one of our speakers
breaking down the latest strategies on
LinkedIn and how you can grow your
business get more customers earn more
money and make a greater difference with
linked-in so definitely go to growth
video live.com to register and make sure
you get your tickets but Michaela what
are results from some of the people that
you've helped you've helped them
optimize their profile just break down
maybe like one or two case studies of
content to connection to business and
how that happens on LinkedIn sure well I
can definitely talk about my own I know
about ninety percent of my business now
comes from my company page which is
something that didn't use to happen I
used to basically use my personal
profile for everything and now having
that company page I've been able to kind
of filter people through to that end
result so definitely like with myself
that's been like my is there like a
sign-up form is it going down in the DM
z-- I mean how does it actually how does
business hello I have landing pages of
course videos with calls to action
it's a big one one of my favorite ways
to convert on LinkedIn is not sexy at
all but it's downloads downloads are
amazing so LinkedIn two things that
people love checklists and templates ooh
power tip so think about it right busy
professionals I always try to imagine
people on LinkedIn they're on their
coffee break they've got a coffee cup in
one hand they've got their phone in the
other they're scrolling through what do
they need what do they need to win and
so I'm constantly putting out checklists
and actually one of my checklist that I
had had for like a year two years when
documents a document feature just came
out on LinkedIn I posted it on there
just see what would happen
1.5 million downloads that is insane I'm
like damn unlimited so the organic and
that's what's really great is that
LinkedIn for organic traction you
probably noticed this it's like it's
unparalleled right because we're still
in that phase of people trying to learn
how to create that we're not at that
point where people are starting to spend
money on ads and actually I have some
insider scoops especially when it comes
to LinkedIn pages and they actually told
me that their focus for the next few
years is to help small to medium-sized
businesses gain we're gonna act a great
organic traction which I mean I don't
know of any platform that will tell you
we want to help businesses gain organic
traction so that's really where their
focus is their customers always been
like the enterprise and now they're
really shifting their focus to smaller
guys and that's that's a really great
thing and I don't know how much you know
about the LinkedIn algorithm but it
actually right now is favoring newer
creators Wow so it's good news it's
called the the Robin Hood algorithm
meaning that older creators like myself
they're actually kind of suppressing
some of the content and then giving that
attention to people that haven't created
before it kind of boosts them up so that
they continue creating yeah and that's
so powerful and of course LinkedIn too
even when you look at new platforms that
have opportunity like a tick-tock and a
LinkedIn those would probably be two of
the hottest ones then you got to think
about the audience yeah LinkedIn is the
wealthiest social network online it's
where business is done is where
professionals are so if you want to grow
your business and have an end result and
it's the Robin Hood algorithm I just
learned about that
then what an opportunity to be building
your influence on LinkedIn in
celebration of the launch of this
brand-new podcast we're giving away two
tickets to our annual conference grow as
video live a fifteen hundred dollar
value all you have to do to enter is
make sure you subscribe leave us a
review on Apple podcast and then take a
screenshot of your review and go to
think marketing show.com for the rest of
the details
absolutely 40% of the world's
millionaires are on LinkedIn currently
that's unreal so do some checklists do
some of those before we go I want to
hear just a couple tactics like best
practices and I'm even thinking I'll
breakdown a little bit of what we're
doing and of course if you haven't been
on LinkedIn go back over there set up
your profile make sure you follow
Michaela Alexis she will help you
optimize your profile and of course the
growth video live should do the same I'm
Sean kennel over on LinkedIn and as we
land the plane give us just I know
you're gonna be breaking out so many
tactics that grow a video live but right
now on LinkedIn I'm doing my best
my team is helping me we're doing some
text posts we're doing some photo we're
doing some videos but what are best
practices and maybe some mistakes that
could be making so the biggest mistakes
that I see especially for people coming
from other platforms number one not
using native video okay
that's number one think of this ranked
into a YouTube video versus a lot of
companies a lot of people linking to a
YouTube or Vimeo link imagine spending
millions of dollars on a feature and
then people are going on and they're
pulling people off of the platform when
they have a feature that's available so
you always want to play to whatever
platform that you're on their algorithm
so you have to think about what they are
trying to achieve and work with them not
against them so that's the number one
thing I see a lot of people trying to as
a call to action saying follow me on
Twitter or check out my youtube channel
I won't tell you something about
LinkedIn that's very unique there are so
many people on LinkedIn
only use LinkedIn as a social media
platform so don't I I have clients that
hate Facebook hate Instagram they think
of LinkedIn as kind of like the anti
social media yeah and they like it feel
safe it feels comfortable and you'll
notice people that like LinkedIn they
don't like LinkedIn
they like love lengthen right they're
all about it and so as a call to action
saying follow me on Twitter check out my
youtube channel those don't work well
because of that community party on
LinkedIn keep the party on LinkedIn I
mean I'm a big believer that you should
be able to give people as much
information as possible so you can kind
of like attract them and close them kind
of in that same piece so I'm all about
pre-qualification on the platform but
definitely make sure in terms of a call
to action the LinkedIn algorithm is also
looking to make sure that you're tagging
people in your posts and that you're
inviting conversation so something
that's interesting about LinkedIn is
that they're really focused not only on
your content but as you're also as your
behavior as a user so not like Instagram
or other features where they don't
really care about who you're commenting
on how many times they're commenting
LinkedIn is actually looking at that got
it they're looking at where you're
spending time in the newsfeed
who else is content you're commenting on
how you're responding and whether or not
you're asking questions inviting
conversation and tagging other users to
bring them in
well you've convinced me and I've been
convinced but every time I talk to you I
get more excited and more pumped about
doubling down on LinkedIn and so make
sure this is in 2020 I think this is one
of the big opportunities right now we've
been paying attention ever since I first
heard you at a VidCon LinkedIn video
creators summit that's when we first met
yeah I shot a video that day and I was
like I'm gonna try I'm now on and we've
been trying and we've been continuing
obviously YouTube takes a lot of our
bandwidth but I have personally for our
team I have said that we can't ignore
LinkedIn we just can't it's just is too
much organic reach like best algorithm
on the internet I love this new creators
thing so think community double down on
LinkedIn get your tickets to grow a
video live.com so you can learn more
from
michaela Alexis and take some action go
sign up to or go follow her on LinkedIn
because what I love is obviously you're
an expert so you can see what you're
doing in your activity see some of your
behaviors see how you've optimized your
profile and I'm sure you have some good
downloads and checklists that can help
us go further so so what anything for
our audience they can check you out on
LinkedIn but what else where else can
they follow you or what should they know
they make Alexis calm is my website so
you can find all of my downloads my
checklist I have writing prompts one
thing that I created recently was a
hundred different ways to repurpose your
content on LinkedIn because I'm all
about using what you've already got
rather than constantly creating it was a
stretch to create a hundred I will say
but I think it's super fun so that's
available on the website and my company
page on LinkedIn is where I house all of
my not only my training content but also
the new features that are coming out on
LinkedIn LinkedIn just announced
yesterday that they're bringing out
stories so make sure that you're
following that so that you get that
those quick tips and all of the new
features ok that was so good Sean it's
making me rethink why am I not on
LinkedIn yet I know that you are on
LinkedIn our companies on LinkedIn but
Heather Torah is not on LinkedIn
Michaela's interview you just did with
her really is pushing me over the edge I
need to get there yeah and you know I
even still because you get your main
platform and I know everybody can relate
because you're like wait a minute we're
learning about tik-tok and LinkedIn and
these different platforms even on the
think marketing podcast it's hard enough
to keep up with just a YouTube channel
but when there is opportunity like that
you got to take action and I don't even
think like what I'm personally doing and
obviously you have to consider I've got
the benefit and the help of having
amazing team members like Heather Taurus
and Melissa Caputo and you know ohm are
helping so we're able to do a scale that
is different than someone who's just
starting so you got to be realistic
about the season you're in but you don't
want to miss the opportunity of a
lifetime
you got to seize it during the lifetime
of the opportunity and that's what's
happening on LinkedIn right now amazing
organic reach amazing opportunity to
connect directly with your target
audience and drive
sails reach customers reach clients and
a lot of people even our community or
sometimes even posting their videos in
both places they're shooting a YouTube
video that's less than 10 minutes and
they're sometimes just editing around
the outro or the you know intro a little
bit and just making it for LinkedIn and
they're uploading it there as well
there's different tactics you can do to
take advantage of the fact that LinkedIn
is just hot right now and you can grow a
ton of influence build your business
faster and the cool thing is that
Makayla is one of our speakers that grow
a video live this year what I love about
our conference is that a lot of the
speaker's unless they have to rush in
and out for some reason are there to
also connect with they answer a lot of
questions they connect with the people
that come and so that way you can
actually get nuances get your questions
answered and learn more about how to
build your business with LinkedIn
LinkedIn is kind of the golden era that
was once at the beginning of YouTube at
the beginnings of Facebook those are
still great but they're more kind of
saturated LinkedIn isn't and I heard
this I think another interview I did
with a different LinkedIn expert was
talking about how out of the almost a
quarter million monthly active users on
LinkedIn only 5% are actively actually
creating content most people love it
they're engaged they're commenting they
love the platform but they're not
creating they're just kind of consuming
reading and connecting therefore the
opportunity as a content creator a
business owner an entrepreneur someone
that wants to drive sales and get
clients and customers I mean you can see
I'm fired up but anyways pumps she's
coming to grow a video live yeah I'm
excited to learn from her again like I
said I really want to go all-in on
LinkedIn this year and so Michaela is
someone that I'm really you know looking
up to as a mentor in this category and
along with Michaela we have a full
lineup of amazing speakers that are
going to be teaching you the best
strategies that are happening on all of
the platforms and you can get all the
details see the best pricing and
packages we have right now for you if
you go to grow with video live.com to
get your ticket yes and we also have to
remind you every week that now is time
to take action
hashtag action takers here at the think
marketing show and look I'm kind of
stealing a page out of Heather's
playbook here she is the product with
productivity queen she is the time
management master I have no idea how she
operates think media while parenting
three kids while her and her husband
Isaiah are homeschooling while doing
things with church and friends and
balancing life at business and hobbies
and health and all of the things but one
of the secrets I've learned from her is
calendar blocking that you have to block
time on your calendar to get these
specific things done so not only do we
want you to write down your next step or
what are you gonna do as a takeaway from
this episode but take some time right
now pull your car over do it tonight do
it soon to sit down and actually put on
your calendar over the next seven days
when are you gonna shoot those next
YouTube videos when are you gonna reply
to comments and then when are you gonna
potentially take 30 to 60 minutes to set
up your LinkedIn profile to consume a
little bit more of Mikayla's content and
actually to just take some action
sometimes because we haven't planned on
paper or digitally on Google Calendar
because we haven't done that we get
overwhelmed but once you start plugging
in priorities on your calendar look you
can get this stuff done and here's the
deal when you take action that's where
the results are yeah and while you're
doing that we want to shout out one of
our think marketing podcasts community
members we read the reviews isn't it
awesome the reviews that we're seeing
online and we're gonna go ahead and
shout out wild Florida who left this
amazing review on the podcast yes here's
the review I'm so excited to hear Sean
and Heather have started this podcast
I've been watching Sean on his think
media video influencers and now think
marketing YouTube channels since I
decided to start a YouTube channel the
videos have helped me walk through each
step from picking a name defining the
niche of the channel getting my first
subscriber and so much more he and
Heather use data with storytelling to
guide you and keep you inspired as you
navigate unknown territory now I can
listen
them as I commute and keep the fuel on
the fire as I work through the grind of
getting my youtube-channel from 0 to
1000 awesome and while Florida we
encourage you to stay connected here
because we want to help you get to that
1000 and if you've not already left a
review you can do that on Apple podcast
and again we are offering two free
tickets our giveaway to grow with video
live if you go to think marketing show
com you'll get all the details simple
steps to enter that giveaway by leaving
a review yes so thanks again for
listening to this episode remember that
sometimes in trying times in life when
there's setbacks when there's obstacles
when it even feels like the whole world
is upside down and every obstacle is
hidden opportunity so stay positive stay
connected to positive people positive
communities and keep building focused on
your dreams goals and vision for your
life and future
we got your back we're in your corner
and we're so pumped that you're
connected here at the think marketing
podcast